i don't want to be like anyone
i want to be an apex predator
barbara what did you do
my life hasn't been what you probably
think it has
we all have our struggles have you ever
been in love
a long long time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
[Music]
welcome to the future life is good
but it can be better then why shouldn't
it be
all you need is to watch
think about finally having everything
you always
wanted i can save today
but
now i take what i want in return
everyone will see
i need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
it's all art
it's uh that's just a trash can it's
just a trash can yeah yeah
welcome back everyone it's charlie big
surprise dc just dropped a new trailer
for wonder woman 1984 so we'll break it
down there's a couple new wonder woman
versus cheetah scenes so i'll explain
what's going on during that there's a
couple big easter eggs
and we have dc fandom trailers coming up
for all the dc movies in a little while
too
so be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos i'll do a special giveaway for dc
fandom
as well they're sending me a bunch of
stuff in a special box i had to sign a
whole bunch of forms to get it so i'll
find out what that is pretty soon
there's also a bunch of new wonder woman
1984 footage that they're going to show
off
separately as part of a big movie
re-release plan that i'll explain later
in the video
i'll number these as we go along but
just going through the footage shot by
shot so most of this new footage focuses
on the cheetah character and what her
transformation to full-blown cheetah is
like during the movie
and how wonder woman reacts to that
along with the big epic battle they get
into after she becomes
full cheetah but the new cheetah scenes
that they put in this trailer are
actually taken from a couple different
places in the movie
is a couple scenes they chopped up and
then jammed together with some voice
over from a different part of the
trailer that aren't necessarily related
the voice over scene in the first part
is barbara minerva talking to maxwell
lord
after he's taken in the full power of
the dreamstone later in the movie
making her second wish asking to become
a true apex predator
that's the final wish she makes to him
in order to become
full comic book cheetah but that's not
actually what her wish
is as you heard her say she says she
doesn't want to be like anyone else
which is just a reference to wonder
woman
she's saying she literally doesn't want
to become wonder woman she wants to be
something different something more
so the dream stone in true twisted movie
fashion as you would expect
interprets her wish in the worst
possible way
by literally turning her into a
monstrous animal-like apex predator
it's a very monkey's paw situation or if
you're a big anime fan it's like the
fate stay series with the grail you make
a wish on the grill but it fulfills your
wish
in the most nightmarish way possible so
cheetah gets all this power but in turn
has to give up her humanity
the second part of that scene is footage
of kristen wiig running really fast like
wonder woman while she still looks like
a human
that's from way earlier in the movie as
she makes her first wish on the dream
stone
and if i didn't say it before the dream
stone is that special black rock that's
the actual name of it it was created by
one of the gods one of the greek gods in
the wonder woman
pantheon but they never say witch god
during the movie
and it's not like the first movie where
there's an actual god in the movie
showing up pulling the strings from
behind it's just maxwell lord and
cheetah being the villains
but the first wish that cheetah makes is
to be just like wonder woman when she's
still barbara minerva like i wish i
could be
just like diana so the dreamstone's
twisted interpretation of that
is that she gets all of wonder woman's
powers taking power from wonder woman
the stone giveth in the stone taketh
away you have to give it something of
yourself in order for its magic to work
so wonder woman winds up giving up her
power without realizing it when she
wishes for steve trevor to come back to
life
and that's how mr fanny pack himself
winds up showing up in the movie
so really is steve trevor running around
but that explains some of the big
power shift twists during the movie it's
kind of a gradual thing through the film
too
like this fight scene here between the
two of them midway through the movie in
the white house
is wonder woman and steve trevor trying
to save the president from max ball lord
and cheetah
but by this time she's gotten way weaker
and cheetah has gotten way
stronger strong enough that she can soak
damage from the lasso of truth like you
can see when she catches it here
winter soldier style so cheetah is
basically upgrading herself through the
course of the film a couple different
times
later in the movie maxwell lord also
upgrades himself using the dream stone
and that's when you see him in the
special broadcast station here
transmitting his power all over the
world simultaneously
and things really go off the rails
that's around the time that cheetah
makes her final wish to become the apex
predator and becomes full cheetah
then as part of that new footage that's
where this scene of wonder woman in the
full gold armor is saying
barbara what did you do like oh hell no
i can't believe you just did this then
they lay into each other in this huge
fight scene
but by this time in the movie she's lost
most of her power
so that explains the logic behind that
golden suit of armor she needs it to
protect herself from cheetah because she
has become so strong at this point
if you've ever watched any of the
animated dc movies they do a lot of
cheetah versus wonder woman
and even when wonder woman is at full
power cheetah is still powerful enough
with her abilities to counter her she's
not quite as strong as wonder woman but
her claws can pierce wonder woman's skin
so you have to imagine that this gold
armor is crazy powerful
the way that wonder woman talks about it
during the movie is that she keeps it
around as an heirloom of the amazons and
it was created by one of her
ancestors who melted down the armor
pieces of a bunch of other amazonians to
just make a really badass suit and it
does a bunch of really cool
things it's not just pure armor the
wings actually work they articulate
they actually fully built a practical
version of this for them to film in the
movie with so you have to picture her
walking around on set between takes
trying not to poke people's eyes out
while they were filming this
wonder woman doesn't really start
getting her power back enough
to fight cheetah till the end of the
movie when she finally comes to grips
with the reality of what the dreamstone
has done
and she has to take back her steve
trevor wish in order to save the world
but that's what this scene of the
trailer is all about where he's
saying you know what you have to do
patty jenkins was also talking about
wonder woman 3 and i know a lot of
people are like
will cheetah come back in future movies
would she ever appear in a suicide squad
sequel because
technically she's a villain of the dc
universe now wonder woman 1984
isn't so much about how wonder woman
defeats villains it's more about how she
tries to save
everyone that also includes the villains
like she tries to save
maxwell lord she also tries to save
cheetah because she used to be her
friend barbara minerva
they kind of established that at the
beginning of the film so you sympathize
with cheetah a little bit more like oh
we can see why she made this choice to
become the cheetah character
but she has this big fall from grace and
unlike wonder woman who is able to take
back her wish and let steve trevor die
again
cheetah is not able to wish away her
powers she still wants to have all these
abilities
so she could always come back during
wonder woman 3 in present day
still in full cheetah form with all of
her powers the way that patty jenkins
talks about it though is that she won't
start working on wonder woman 3
for a little while it'll probably take
about three years to get that movie out
and she said that that would be her very
last wonder woman movie
at dc it's still years away so i
wouldn't worry too much about that right
now they're just taking it one movie at
a time
if you're a big pedro pascal fan though
he's on fire in the movie and obviously
there's all the mandalorian season two
stuff coming up
in a couple weeks they'll be dropping
all those dc fandom trailers i'll try to
do as many of those videos as i can it's
gonna be a lot of stuff it'll be really
cool though
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
in the special new wonder woman 1984
footage
is supposed to screen during the
inception re-release in movie theaters
but while you wait for everything
everyone click here for that brand new
marvel shang chi teaser in iron man
easter eggs and click here for that
brand new
ryan reynolds justice league snyder cut
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay
safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you